-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
It is time to play
a game of deception called
"True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My first opponent tonight is an
incredibly talented actress,
whose new movie,
"Enola Holmes 2,"
comes out on Netflix
November 4th.
Please welcome
Millie Bobby Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! Perfect.
That's Millie Bobby Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Millie, nice.
You came right in there.
Millie and I will be
facing off against
one of her co-stars on
"Stranger Things."
Please welcome the one-and-only
Noah Schnapp!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
-Don't get scalded
by the coffee.
You okay, buddy?
You came in hot, buddy. Wow.
-I did not expect that.
-Yeah, came in hot there.
Alright, perfect.
Alright, here's how this works.
-I'm so sorry.
-No, it's too late now.
-Only Noah.
-Alright.
In front of each of us...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then you have to come
to a unanimous decision --
is it a truth or a lie?
Millie,
you're going to go first.
Which envelope should she open?
What do you think?
1 or 2?
-Oh, we pick?
-Yeah, or the audience
could pick.
What do you think?
-2.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
2!
-Everyone said 2.
I don't know why.
-I sneak my pet bunny
into hotels.
♪♪
-That's...
-You know Millie very well.
-I think that sounds
like it could be real.
-Why would you sneak your bunny?
Why can't you just check it in?
-Millie is, like,
obsessed with animals.
-Alright. But why do you
have to sneak it in?
-Because, usually,
they let in dogs and cats,
but probably not a rabbit.
You know?
It might become an issue.
-What do you mean?
Because that feels like --
Well, you would know
it's an issue, right, if you
already -- If you tried --
-I feel like Millie, though,
wouldn't be sneaky about it.
She would just walk in.
-Yeah, because
she just loves animals.
Yeah, she would just
walk in and say,
"Hey, I have my bunny with me."
-Yeah, she wouldn't care.
-Everyone loves you.
Everyone would let you in
with anything.
You can go in with a chainsaw
and like,
"Yeah, I'm going to go to
my room with a chainsaw."
They'd go, "Millie, come on in.
We love you."
-Maybe.
-I don't think --
-I'm saying lie.
-Oh, wait. Whoa, whoa. Wait.
-But then I've got to
pay a deposit
if he does something, right?
It's like, uh,
do I really want to do that?
No.
-She's so lying.
Are you kidding me?
She's such a liar.
-Why would you stay in a hotel?
Don't you live in England?
-I do, but I was
filming in the city.
-No, this is --
I know when she's acting.
This is a lie.
-This is a
total, complete, absolute lie.
-Like, you can't even try.
-You can't even describe this.
This is such a lie.
Tell us right now --
truth or lie?
[ Drumroll ]
-It's the truth.
-No!
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Guys!
-You played us.
-Why did I come here?
-Dude!
-You played us like
a deck of cards.
-Wait.
I said truth from the beginning.
-Yeah, you did say -- Yeah.
-I knew it.
My instincts said true.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, no. It's a true story.
And it did become an issue.
Like, they guy --
-Did they find it?
-They did.
I went into the elevator
and I put him under my sweater.
And if they ask,
"I'm breast-feeding my child.
Why would you ever ask me?
That's so inappropriate.
Where's your H.R. lady?"
Anyways...
And then, he buzzes
when he gets really happy,
and he was buzzing
under my shirt.
And his ear came out
of my shirt,
and the guy looks.
And I went, "Look away."
And I got off.
And then I put on my
"do not disturb" sign
on my door for like five days.
-So you did get away with it.
-I did, I did, yeah.
-Oh, my God. Alright.
Good job. Congrats.
Good on you.
You got points for that one.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-Oh, my God!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Dude!
-1.
-We'll go with 1.
-Okay, be careful, 'cause I
don't want to be able
to see through -- Okay.
Oh, yeah, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah. I got worried.
-LeBron James called me
from the court during a game.
-That's so cool.
-That's really cool.
I think it's almost
too cool...for you.
-For me?
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
"I think it's almost
too cool...for you."
Yeah.
-Okay. When?
-This was probably about
four years ago.
-Who were they playing?
-Oh, four years ago?
-They were playing the Nuggets.
Or, no, the Warriors.
The Warriors.
Golden State Warriors.
-What did you talk about?
-What do you mean?
They didn't have a chat.
He was just --
-He called you.
Well, he called you.
Did you answer?
-Yes, I did.
-And what did you say?
-So, what happened was,
I went --
-You're lying.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he's lying.
-I feel like I almost --
-I'm going to take this.
I'm gonna dip this in
a little bit more coffee
and let you think.
Think it over.
-Okay, what do we say?
-Ew!
-What do we say?
What do we say? What do we say?
-What is that?
-Alright, together.
-It's a lie.
[ Drumroll ]
-It is a lie, yeah.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
-He would never do that.
He would never do that.
-Never do that.
-He would never do that
during a game.
You knew it.
Noah, it is your turn.
Noah, which one?
-1!
-Okay, 1.
-Come on, bud. We got this.
Enola, let's put our
detective skills to the test.
-I guilt-tripped Shawn Mendes
into following me back
on Instagram.
-This is something he would do.
-It sounds like something --
Yeah, it sounds like --
When is this?
-A year or two ago.
-Okay, why did you
guilt-trip him?
He didn't want to follow you?
-Well, he followed everyone else
in the cast except me.
-Shawn Mendes?
-Yeah. He followed you, Sadie,
Gaten, Caleb -- everybody.
-Oh, he's bitter.
-What's his problem?
-Yeah, he's mad.
-This is real.
-And I was like, "What the heck?
Why does he
follow everyone but me?"
-Yeah, what's
Shawn Mendes' problem?
-You're lying.
-He has beef with me.
-So, then how did you
get ahold of Shawn Mendes?
-I DM'd him and I was like,
"I'm low-key offended.
Why do you follow everyone --"
-Did you say,
"I'm low-key offended"?
You said that to him?
-You can't DM someone
if they're not following you.
He's lying!
-No, no, no.
Jimmy, that's not -- Jimmy...
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, am I -- Did I just
show how old I am?
-He showed his age there.
-Shh.
-Okay. I thought you had to
follow each other to DM.
-No!
-No, you can DM anybody.
-You can DM anybody?
-Jimmy, Jimmy, stop.
You need to stop.
-I'm not even on --
I'm on BeReal now.
-Oh, he's so hip.
-I don't even care.
-What did he say?
-Yeah, what did "Men-Men" say?
-He said, "Oh, what's up, man.
Like, I love you so much."
-He does say, "What's up, man?"
He does use the word "man."
He's like, "Hey, man."
He's Canadian.
-He's a fellow Canadian.
And he was like --
-Shawn -- Well,
he's a very nice guy, Shawn.
-Oh, I'm sweating.
-When is the last time you
talked to Shawn on Instagram?
-I called him the other day.
-Oh.
-That is absolutely --
This such a lie.
-Yeah.
-That was what -- That's it.
It's over. It's over.
-It's a lie.
-You called him the other day?
Why would you call him if you
have him on -- If you're DMing?
I'm going to say it's a lie.
-It's a lie.
-It's...the truth.
-What?!
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
Wow!
Wow! Acting. Acting.
Mastermind. Noah Schnapp.
-Oh, my God!
-He did it again.
-My thanks to
Millie Bobby Brown,
Noah Schnapp.
"Bron-Bron," give me a call.
We're talking to Millie
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Thank you, Noah!